bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fari j
scusatemi ragazze ieri non ho messo
video ma per problemi di studio non sono
riuscito a pubblicarlo
vabbè oggi siamo di nuovo su scrive l'on
mi trovo davanti al corpo un indiana
jones che ho fatto fuori nello scorso
episodio grazie all'arca dell'alleanza
fantastica
va beh direi di cambiare zona eravamo
praticamente nella città di atlantide
sommersa è praticamente ci sono ancora
due zone che devo sbarcare non vi
ricorda quante start stop
non me lo ricordo però vabbè poi adesso
vedo fenomeni prendo una e direi di
andare qui che non so o dio c'è di
muller quest c'è di nuovo hercules è il
bigfoot ok è fantastico che ci sono
tutti c'è anche balto è fantastico primo
livello dove la st wright mela sbattono
direttamente in faccia
quindi rei di provare odio ce gandhi
ma che cazzo vabbè tre scalatori hanno
bisogno di max per raggiungere la cima
alle punto esclamativo ok
questo è il mondo perché la che cazzo ne
so io perché la noi iniziamo il monte
punto esclamativo ancora mi mancava raga
questi tre amici stanno scalando la
montagna rimuove da valanga che blocca
il loro percorso ok c'è einstein gambi è
una che non è the leaky sia tra l'altro
mi dovete spiegare perché sono vestito
tipo uno di quei russi che ballano tutti
così va bene non importa
vabbè buttiamo giù una valanga che ne so
bulldozer perfetto ragazzi siamo col
bulldozer forse un po troppo piccolo
vabbè proviamoci lo stesso ok non ce la
sto facendo per usa veicolo se ci metto
due aree così i ragazzi serve un po più
grosso facciamo tipo aggettivo gigante
ok adesso addio che cazzo succede
bene sono arrivati in cima alla montagna
non mi chiedete come oddio è che cazzo
che sta succedendo
vabbè non sto capendo raga sono
diventato gigante anch'io ma perché
ragazzo.la valanga direi di prenderla ca
citate come calciare un sassolino
sono partito malissimo rag allora devo
riuscire a spostare sta roba dinamite
giganti ma come cazzo scrivo dinamite
gigante speriamo che diamante no
distante demente demente gigante cos'è
che fa brutto stronzo no tnt raga prova
a metterne sempre di più voglio provare
a vedere se mettere sempre di più riesco
a fare qualcosa perché se noi ci metto
delle ora allora tiene ti tiene ti
ovunque
ok lo metto qua perfetto adesso se se
tutto va bene dovrei riuscire per merda
via perfetto godiamoci l'esplosione che
dopo un'ora ragazza dopo un'ora ci sono
riuscito pensate che questa era soltanto
la prima sfida va beh direi che posso
provare a passare al livello successivo
se ci ho messo un'ora per il primo
livello non oso pensare oddio piovono
nuvole più o meno nuovo chi cazzo è
questo e l'arci nemico di thor i giganti
di ghiaccio hanno scatenato
un'improvvisa tempesta creata oggetti
che aiuteranno gli scalatori a resistere
al freddo
questa è una cosa veramente stranissima
però direi che una coperta coperta
gigante in questo caso fa al caso vostro
se copritevi tutti
copritevi come se fosse la fine del
mondo è vedi brutto stronzo
mi è venuto in mente raja che a sto
punto mi servirebbe anche un verbo
sifone gigante perfetto anche questo
serve in questi casi è a sto punto per
concludere direi un cappello gigante un
bel no veramente un cappello si tipo
questo kg
ma cos'è ho dato un cappello giganta
gandhi è va beh direi che possiamo
andare avanti
addio addio mi sembra tipo super mario
lo yeti arrabbiato tratta con lui modo
che gli alpinisti possano motivare a
scalare la montagna ma non ucciderlo ok
questo dovrei dare allo yeti per
intrattenerlo che ne so io ok raga mi
devo improvvisare tipo dio o c'era che
mi deve improvvisare tipo supermario
però evidentemente non me la cavo molto
bene raga l'unica cosa che mi viene in
mente una cosa veramente folle però per
farla mi serve un qualcosa per volare
perché io lì non ci arrivo se no è lì
elicottero prova elicottero ragazzi non
so scrivere non so scrivere
vabbè elicottero proviamo a fare sta
cosa qui perché sennò non sapevo cosa
fare la gara
ora andiamo lì aggiunge aggettivo visto
che bello incazzato scriviamo calmo
proviamo così
ok no evidentemente ancora incassato
quindi proviamo con gentile
adesso genia noah gentile perfetto
quello scritto io non è che vista
perfetto è diventato il professor layton
improvvisamente però sono riuscito a
farlo calmare perfetto c'è odio gli
alpinisti sono quasi sulla vetta metti
sulla vetta un oggetto che gli alpini si
vorrebbero ok
secondo me vorrebbero una banana
perfetto ma che cazzo stanno arrivando
tutti però è perfetto ve l'ho lasciata
lì su prendetela è ok o triturato la
banana
ho fatto un frappé cosa possono avere la
bandiera bandiera giga tutto ci gara da
oggi è tutto gigante va è perfetto cosa
sta facendo si sta arrampicando su una
bandiera ma perché va datemi un perché
si è arrampicato sulla bandiera al
contrario va beh io raga me ne vado di
qua il prima possibile
abbiamo preso la st wright siamo adesso
vedremo quanto siamo perché
effettivamente non lo so neanch'io 28 me
ne mancano due per poter sbloccare
l'altra zona ok ragazze la posso fare
prima di oggi voglio sbloccarmi appunto
l'altra zona perché sennò siamo troppo
fermi c'è cos'è cosa sta facendo
buongiorno ha bisogno d'aiuto questa
scultura e noiosa per ispirarmi mettimi
qualcosa sulla piattaforma di legno laga
direi una banana di ghiaccio e la
scultura migliore che mi possa venire in
mente in questo momento vice coltissima
banana che cazzo che senso ha tutto
questo va beh grazie mille per la
scultura è fantastica la prossima volta
fabbrico fa vj di ghiaccio così mi fai
una fan art perché l'hai fatta
praticamente uguale cos'è questo oddio
sembra quello di jack and daxter
invecchiato però va bè l'altro già
raga e lui è evidentemente un altro di
quei riferimenti di scribblenauts epici
che hanno fatto nel gioco allora cosa
che devo fare
devo far rumore o che è perfetto come
faccio a far rumore da damina chitarra
elettrica e ti faccio tutto il casino
che vuoi vai perfetto
vai suona ok lo sta facendo si stanno o
giro che cazzo è questa ragano non lo
zio c'è un impiccato
c'è un input perché c'è un impiccato ok
ma non è impiccato si stanno si stanno
arrampicando ma che ne so io vedo uno
così sembra impiccato che ne so io la
parola comunque a indovinare era sempre
comunque nutella aiutaci a scendere no
adesso ti lascio così cazzi tuoi
imparavi ad arrampicarti come avete
fatto a finire lì sopra idea ma domanda
chi da elicottero elicottero elicottero
perfetto con l'elicottero raga posso
provare a tagliarla ci siano perfetto ok
ok posizione precaria era veramente il
suo livello hanno bisogno tutti gli
aiuto perché ne approfitto così almeno
cerco di prendere più st wright
possibili poi avvantaggiarmi nella corsa
è che ne so a calci in culo a sto punto
che so io blocco appunti a sto punto
metterei veloce perché se no non so che
cosa fare
vai avanti 2 1 vai perfetto ce l'ho
fatta non posso saltare abbastanza in
alto per seguire mamma capra state
pensando quello che penso io spero di sì
e trampolino ci siamo ragazzi amo
tornati vai
ce l'abbiamo fatta
[Musica]
il trampolino sarà sempre comunque fa
e tu fai
[Musica]
oddio mi vanno a fuoco le mutande mi
mandano al fiammifero ancora che cazzo
pensavo mi stesso andando a fuoco tipo
il vestito va beh buongiorno ho bisogno
di qualcosa e pericoloso paura di
saltare anche qui un calcio in culo non
farebbe male però diciamo coraggioso e
l'aggettivo migliore coraggioso perfetto
ma si sa bene ci stava bene il
trampolino anche qui adesso che ci penso
però va bene lo stesso
direi che abbiamo aiutato praticamente
tutti comportati come uno yeti e saremo
amici gigante spaventoso spaventoso che
è perfetto
altro non mi viene in mente amico dello
yeti perfetto
direi che ho finito praticamente tutto
mi manca soltanto una st wright e poi mi
sbloccherò il paesaggio successivo e poi
sbloccarmi ovviamente devo dare nella
nuova zona
ok che mi sembra anche più carina ci
sono quelli che fanno snowboard è ok io
so fare soltanto wakeboard ma snowboard
no chi è quello è un fratello di maxwell
non so perché è uguale lo riconosco
perché è uguale identico allora c'è un
acaro no brutto stronzo non farei del
marocco il coniglio già ho perso fusi
una volta non perderò mai quel coniglio
è ok
devo decidere se aiutare coniglio lui
questa trappola veramente pericolosa fai
qualcosa
a sto punto direi di mandarci che ne so
un cerbiatto ci mando un cerbiatto lì
sopra così ci siamo è perfetta da
[ __ ] ok ma non scatta la tua non
funziona trappola sei tranquillo
e non funziona c'è il cerbiatto ci sta
saltando sopra praticamente
non lo so che cosa inoffensiva ok ci
sono amici pelosi spaventati
che senso ha tutto questo e vabbè brutto
stronzo così impari a uccidere gli
animali indifesi
ok ci siamo ragas da wright è successo
qualcosa a babbo natale aiuta risolvere
il mistero nov
babbo natale non me lo toccate babbo
natale non me lo dovete toccare alla
ricerca di babbo natale 6 con la
macchina della polizia e odio si è
schiantato risotto lo vedo lo vedo il
babbo natale è stato vittima di un
sabotaggio ed è scomparso mai 18 cazzo
di spunta che appello dai a sua moglie
il documento appropriato per accedere
alla scena del crimine
allora abbiamo clint eastwood è la
voglia di babbo natale buongiorno
signora è cosa devo fare
devo fare qui da adesso voglio un
documento appropriato per accedere a
scena recrimina ok
che ne so documento commento
perfetto magari è la lista della spesa
ma va bene lo stesso ma la voglia di
babbo natale poteva accedere lo stesso
sembra che la slitta sia stata sabotata
dai agli investigatori qualcosa per
prendere le impronte digitali
devo fare tutto io praticamente da soli
non fanno un cazzo perché io il
paraorecchie vabbè allora andiamo di su
jet pack jetpack ok andiamo lì sopra un
attimo cosa devo fare devo dare lente
lente d'ingrandimento
ok senza l'apostrofo mai con il fronte
digitali con la lente di ingrandimento a
caso la madonna el'impronta nel big foot
che cos'è c'è di nuovo jack le impronte
digitali sono quelli di jack frost jack
frost è un film che ho visto io
effettivamente la mio film preferito da
bambino però quello non è il jack che
intendo io quello è quello di jak and
daxter ma non fa niente dai qualcosa
alle tecniche per eseguire
l'interrogatorio ok la bocca che cosa
cazzo ci devo dare effettivamente però
non c'era la bocca quindi diamogli la
bocca per parlare bocca anatomia ok by
esegui l'interrogatorio come si fa a
prendere sul serio una persona del
genere e che ne so io a ciel annuncia la
bocca
da lì qualcosa per interrogare jack
frost ma jack frost non era così era un
pupazzo di neve va beh lasciamo perdere
io dire raga mi ha venduto negazioni al
e direi di minacciarlo con un phon che
come è letale come se fosse una pistola
ok ha funzionato si sta sciogliendo
l'ho ucciso jack frost poverino era
l'idolo della mia infanzia the frost ha
confessato che babbo natale e qui vicina
come mi è venuto in mente di fabbricare
un fan
va bene qui vicenda ya segugio qualcosa
che appartiene proprio a tale per
ritrovarlo
oh cazzo c'è il cappello di babbo natale
che è più grosso del phon ma non puoi
non vederlo che cosa ci devo dare a
segugio non so e non lo so io direi
dolci proviamo a dolce proviamo ad
invogliarlo a cercare babbo natale altro
non mi viene in mente una crostata
perfetto mangiati sacro stata e poi vai
a trovare babbo natale ok non ci devi
cagare sopra una cosa o dio è morto
no è morto perché oddio è spuntato il
vero babbo natale ma non è morto allora
ok è l'amore trionfa un'altra volta
e io che pensavo fosse morto ma in
verità non era lì sotto allora mi
sbagliavo fin dall'inizio
ricordate ragazzi che se vedete un
cappello di babbo natale in mezzo alla
neve non è necessariamente babbo natale
sepolto vivo e detto questo posso
prendere la st wright ragazzi siamo
abbiamo preso 3 st wright
siamo a 30 mi sono sbloccato dalla zona
nuova
la cosa veramente epica raga che non
veramente non so come mi è venuto in
mente è stato minacciare jack frost call
phone è stato geniale secondo me non so
come mi è venuto in mente la vabbè è ok
buongiorno a lei mica un barbaro ok c'è
che cazzo e billy the kid ti ha rubato
il t ha rubato tir rubato i saldi ma tu
che epica sta cosa mi sono sbloccato il
west maraga sarà veramente fantastico
secondo me la parte della neve raga
finora è stata la più noiosa tra
virgolette a parte jack frost è lo yeti
ovviamente secondo me la parte del far
west sarà veramente fantastica spero di
riuscire a farla quando la voce magari
vi tornerà anche normale e non solo
quanto siamo arrivati di minuti di video
però io direi di stoppare qua perché
come al solito raga la mia voce
ultimamente non mi permette di fare
chissà cosa mi sembravano legamento di
aver visto bin laden lì sotto ma vabbè
c'è un fratello di marx perché tra
l'altro mi sono dimenticato di
incontrare il fratello di marzo ed anche
prima
c'è un pinguino perché c'è un pinguino
nel deserto e oddio c'è una c'è una
lampada da strofinare raga c'è una
lampada l'astro finale ma scoprirete
tutto nel prossimo episodio
la chiudo qui raga perché veramente la
mia voce ultimamente mi sta abbandonando
appena posto come promesso faccio
l'episodio eleonora che mi avete chiesto
da secoli come al solito ragazze vi dove
è piaciuto ha lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook che
come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione se non siete fuori city
scrivetevi noi ci vediamo al prossimo
lido bella ragazzi
[Musica]